Let's look at the answer for
our way prediction quiz.
We can use way prediction in any cache
that has more than one block in a set.
A direct-mapped cache has
only one block in a set.
So we can not use way prediction.
Basically, a direct-map cache
already knows which one blocked to
access without having to guess.
In any set-associative, or
fully associated cache,
we can benefit from way prediction.
For example for
a twoway set-associative cache,
we can guess which on of the two
is more likely to have the block.
In an eight-way set-associative cache,
we're guessing which one of the eight.
And in a fully associative cache,
we are guessing
which block in the whole cache is
the most likely to have the block.
So the correct answer is,
that these should be selected, and
this one should not.